At this point you experienced and
are starting to build mastery in
a lot of the key ideas that
underline all of programming.
And what that means is,
now you have options.
The point of the rest of this noun
degree is to expose you to what some of
those options are.
Because there is a ton of cool
things you can do at this point.
Now, because we're gong for exposure,
and not mastery, we're going to go
quick, and there's going to be times
where that feels really overwhelming.
On top of that, when you go
to the forums and you ask for
help, there's a good chance a coach
may not even know the answer.
That's to be expected.
Instead, you should expect to get advice
about how to solve problems in general,
rather than specific
answers to your question.
Good luck, and have fun.